this video is brought to you by magellan tv
a new documentary streaming service founded
by filmmakers who love history their mission
is to tell the great stories that have defined
the human experience and with more than 3 000
excellent programs available on magellan it's
hard to stop once you start they've got everything
from the greeks to the great war plus modern
history biographies scientific profiles true crime
and well so much more and their team adds more
content every single week and what's one thing
you love about paid streaming services of course
there are no ads just great great content they've
got great playlists of content covering both macro
and micro facets of antiquity in the roman
empire including titles like rome empire
without limits so if you already binged through
all of our playlists on rome and romans and are
looking for more content then of course you need
to give magellan a look right now you guys can get
a one month free trial with magellan by clicking
on the link in the description below it's content
for days and days so let magellan hook you up
you'll be glad you did and back to today's video
for most americans he's a historical bogeyman
the mexican leader who massacred the defenders
of the alamo and then lost texas in a
revolution if people north of the border
know much more about him it's often limited to
his comeback role in the mexican-american war
or perhaps his legendary vainglorious excesses
but there was so much more to santa anna than
a footnote role in us history far from cartoonish
villain he was a consummate political survivor one
so capable he managed to single-handedly
dominate mexican politics for over 30 years
born antonio lopez de santa ana in the port
city of veracruz santa ana had an ability to
shapeshift like no other whether as royalist or
rebel liberal or conservative democrat or dictator
he always found a way to not just
survive the change of political winds
but thrive the one constant in a half century
of chaos holder of the presidency no less than
11 times this is the story of the man who shaped
mexico's destiny both for better and for worse
fragile winds up repeatedly becoming president of
his nation perhaps the most surprising thing about
santorana is that he never really wanted mexico
to be independent born in zalapa near veracruz
on february 21 1794 antonio lopez de santa anna
grew up as a beneficiary of spanish rule mexico at
this time was the vice royalty of new spain bear
moth including not just modern-day mexico but also
central america and huge chunks of what we'd call
the southwestern u.s this was a world segregated
along strict lines one that placed the boy's
family near the top his parents were creoles
people of ethnic spanish descent who'd been born
in the new world while they ranked below the
peninsulares people born in spain proper they did
more than okay for themselves santana's dad owned
estates and had made some money doing business
for the spanish crown they weren't rich but they
were wealthy enough that santa ana could drop
out of school and still land a decent job with
a merchant in veracruz new spain's key port not
that it was business the boy had his heart on
but the military at the age of 16 santa ana
started pestering his dad about joining the
army despite having served himself as pop push
back reluctant to allow his son to become a
cadet but if there was one thing santarana was
good at even age 16 it was persuading people
to let him do what he wanted so it was that in
june 1810 he enrolled in the army of new spain
if you know anything about mexican history you'll
know that this was some especially bad timing 1810
was when the viceroyalty collectively lost it
just two years earlier napoleon had deposed the
board monarchy in spain in south america this had
been the trigger for the wars of independence but
new spain had so far resisted the cry of
revolution no the key phrase there so far at the
time santorana joined the cadets a region known as
the baio was on the cusp of exploding the silver
mining region by had been walloped by an economic
crisis and now famine despair and resentment were
its main exports it was in this fertile soul
that don miguel hidalgo would plant the seeds
of mexican independence sadly we don't have time
to go into hidalgo today hopefully we can give
him another video all his own at some point but
just know that he was a priest who hated poverty
almost as much as he loved the idea of splitting
off from spain on september 16 1810 he combined
these two themes into the fabled cryolores the
most famous speech in mexican history the cry was
a call for his poverty-stricken congregation
to take up arms to overthrow the viceroyalty
far more so than napoleon deposing the king
this speech turned the people into a republican
army one that swept across new spain but rather
than take part in mexico's independence struggle
santa anna would try to crush it as a new recruit
santa ana was placed under the command of joaquin
de arradondo and set out to destroy the rebels
since the mexican war of independence was a
total [ __ ] show that original mission soon span
off into also fighting both indian uprisings and
incursions from private adventurers known as
filibusters it was this latter group that in
1812 saw santa ana deployed to texas there he
was spellbound by both aradondo's brutality and
his brilliance a strategic genius aradondo
was able to pull off stuff like the battle
of medina which saw him reduce a rebel force of
1400 to just 100 survivors by simply choosing
his defensive position well but it was what
came next that really left an impression on
the teenage soldier arredondo followed up his
victories by not just mass executing rebels but
also punishing their families and placing whole
towns under martial law the tactics were cruel
but they were also effective it was a military
lesson the young santa anna would never forget
as the war dragged on it began to look
like santa ana had picked his side well
after years of extremely bloody fighting hidalgo
was long dead meanwhile the bourbon monarchy had
been restored to the spanish throne then in 1816 a
brand new viceroy was sent over from spain one who
was less like kill the rebel scum and more like
maybe we could reach some kind of agreement yes
it seemed like the war was winding down
and santa anna was winding down with it
now in his mid-twenties he'd gone from fighting
indians to being part of a group that helped
rebuild their villages although disciplined
for misusing his unit's funds he'd also risen
up the ranks it could have been the beginning
of a long successful career in new spain's army
had newspaper not been on the cusp of complete
collapse in 1820 a mutiny and the spanish porter
cadiz saw a new liberal constitution forced upon
the king overnight staying under the monarchy
went from something new spain's conservatives
desperately wanted to something about as appealing
as a hamburger made of anthrax the first to
switch sides was augustine de ituberdi supposedly
the head of the anti-rebel forces turboday
instead crossed the lines in early 1821 joining
forces with one of the biggest rebel groups
together they marched on the capital it was
at this moment that santa ana made his first great
pivot declaring himself in support of the rebels
he took control of veracruz bringing it over to
the republican side and he couldn't have timed
it any better as we'll repeatedly see the genius
of santa anna wasn't that he often switched sides
but that he usually did so with impeccable
timing at the moment when his new support
counted the most seeing the growing rebellion new
spain threw in the towel negotiations were opened
and on september the 28th mexico was declared an
independent state while not key to victory santa
ana's pivot to the rebels was still recognized he
was promoted to general in his new role he fully
supported its erbido's post-independence power
grab plodding as the former soldier declared
himself emperor augustine the first of mexico but
the first mexican empire was way too unstable for
santa anna to stick on side for long as emperor
augustine was less an augustus than he was a
budding palpatine a paranoid a repressive
tyrant he shut dissolved congress moved to set
up a dictatorship but his stupidest move came in
veracruz not liking santorana's obvious ambition
augustine seized on financial irregularities to
strip the general of his rank unfortunately he
did this just as it was becoming clear that it
alienated all of his supporters with impeccable
timing santa anna switched sides again declaring
himself in support of the dissolved congress
in reality the only thing he really supported
was santarana but the results were still the same
after santa aranna broke other generals followed
that winter all the heroes of the independence
war one by one came out against augustine on
march 19 1823 the first mexican emperor resigned
fleeing into exile his exit led to the
central american states jumping ship from
mexico significantly reducing the young nation's
territory but it also led to the restoration of
the republic although he championed it at the
time santana later admitted that he had no idea
what republicanism really involved so long as it
meant he was on the winning side though anything
was fine by him as the restored congress began to
reorganize mexico santarana took a step back from
public life he exited the military became the
civilian governor of veracruz he married inez
garcia but if anyone assumed that that was the
end of mexico's man of destiny they couldn't have
been more wrong santa anna's story and his hold
over this young country was only just beginning
the fall of augustine gave everyone an unwelcome
taste of the divisions that would soon split
mexico on one side stood the conservatives in all
their pro-church pro-strong leader pro-centralized
state glory on the other stood the liberals who
mixed a desire for social justice with an even
bigger desire for power to be devolved to mexico's
individual states after augustine fled it was the
liberals who emerged triumphant writing a brand
new constitution that gave the federal government
almost no power over the states unfortunately this
coincided with a massive economic slump unable to
effectively raise taxes the government defaulted
on its loans poverty began to stalk the nation it
was against this dark background that the faithful
election of 1828 was held if you thought the
2020 u.s election was divisive just know that
mexico's 1828 election makes it look like the
model of gentlemanly conduct there were riots
uprisings disorder which lasted not just for years
but for decades from 1828 to 1855 the mexican
presidency would change hands no less than 48
different times get to guess which political
chameleon benefited from the chaos as the echoes
of that terrible election reverberated across the
nation santorana was finding himself more popular
than ever he was helped in this by spain which
decided the 1828 debacle represented a golden
opportunity to land an expeditionary force and
retake the country instead they landed at tampico
only for santarana to raise an army charged
down and single-handedly forced them to retreat
this is so heroic that grateful mexicans
christened santarana the napoleon of the west
a name he who his characteristic ego seems to have
suggested himself yet who could really disagree
by now santa anarid helped see off vice royalty
an emperor and the spanish navy who knew
what his next step would be actually anastasio
bustamante thoughts he might have a pretty good
idea supposedly the vice president bustamante had
overthrown his boss in december of 1829 and was
now in the process of turning mexico into a loose
federation of states in another augustine-style
centralized dictatorship the only problem was that
each state tended to have its own regional strong
man or caudillo none of whom were eager to give
up any power realizing the cardios might rebel
bustamante tried to beat them to it dispatching
the army to kill santa anna sadly for him this
went about as well as ned flanders trying to take
on the incredible hulk when he got wind of the
approaching army santa ana went on the attack
driving them out of veracruz out of his state
and all the way back to the capital in december
1832 his men marched triumphantly into mexico city
defeated bustamante fled into temporary exile
the fourth leader that santorena had helped
overthrow this time though the man of destiny
was through with simply deposing bad governments
now he wanted to lead one antonio lopez de
santiago became mexico's eighth president in may
of 1833. his ascension was seen as a triumph for
mexico's liberals at first it really was santarana
was a true cordillo a guy for him having power
was a lot more fun than actually exercising it
after a short stay in the capital he put his
vp the radical liberal valentine gomez perez
in charge and he went home to veracruz to enjoy
his shiny new title but if the liberals thought
santorana's shape-shifting days were over they
were in for a bit of a nasty shock by 1835
farrier's radical reforms had pissed off so many
people that revolts were breaking out rather
than back his guy though zanderana road back to
mexico city overthrew him and announced himself
the head of a new conservative dictatorship it
was a head-spinning move a political shift so
jarring it induced whiplash and there was
worse to come the cordillo who delivered
mexico from multiple despots was now about to
become one of the most despotic of all of them
santorina's transformation from liberal champion
to conservative tyrants was nothing if not
wholehearted imagine if bernie sanders showed up
tomorrow at a maga rally leading chance of stop
the steal your brain just probably wouldn't be
able to grasp it right well santa anna's pivot
was that weirdness times a million having decided
that tacking right was the only way to stay in
power the president now went all in congress
was dissolved leading liberals sent into exile
finally in late 1835 la siete de leia saw the
seven laws were published stripping the states of
their powers and dumping them all in the hands of
santa anna for historians this is the point when
mexico's first republic ends replaced by something
called the centralist republic for people at the
time though it was an outrage rebellions blew
up across the nation most famously in zacatecas
and of course texas in most english language
documentaries on santorana this is where the meat
of the story lies in a detailed account of his
screw-ups in the texas revolution but that's not
what we're aiming for our goal here is to give you
a decent overview of his entire life rather than
the bits that you've already heard in grade school
of course the downside is that we're about to piss
off a whole bunch of texans by barely spending two
minutes on their foundational story so sorry about
all the stuff we're about to miss out guys please
feel free to completely overreact in the comments
below not long after texas erupted tantarana
personally rode north at the head of seven
thousand men to put down the rebellion although
his army was under-equipped things started pretty
well in february 1836 they laid siege to a small
spanish mission that the texans had overrun known
as the alamo it fell in a bloody battle in early
march one that ended with santorana having all the
captured men executed a lesson had learned long
ago watching joachim de arradondo do his bloody
work still tantarana wasn't all bad he let the
women children and enslaved people who'd been at
the alamo go free but this act of clemency was
just a one-off santa rana had after all studied
hard under arendondo and he was determined to do
his old commander proud the pinnacle of this came
with the goliad massacre on march the 27th
between 350 and 425 texan prisoners of war
were murdered under santa ana's orders despite
his mexican commanders begging him to reconsider
but this turned out to be a legendary pr blunder
the new coke of war crimes the rage generated by
the massacre go to the texians on on april 21st
they hit santa rana with a surprise ambush yelling
remember the alamo remember goliad the battle of
san jacinto was frankly an embarrassment for the
cadilla president captured with the threat of
execution hanging over him zandarana was forced
to pivot again from bloodthirsty dictator to man
desperate to cut a deal that deal signed in may of
1836 declared mexico would both withdraw all of
its troops from texas and recognize the state's
independence in return santarana would return home
alive it was hardly a great homecoming note when
santarana arrived back in mexico his name was
worse than mud worse than manure he resigned
the presidency retired to his hatiander and left
politics seemingly for good after all there was no
way anyone could recover from such a disaster
right but santiago wasn't just anyone he was
perhaps mexico's greatest political survivor and
all it would take to change his fortunes would be
one unhappy baker a few years earlier mexico city
had been gripped in one of the periodic waves of
unrest that followed 1828 amid the rioting a
french pastry shop was trashed supposedly by
mexican soldiers from this minor incident santa
anna would soon engineer a comeback so great that
he'd be able to maintain his stranglehold
on mexican politics for another 20 years
in terms of things to start a war over
a damaged pastry shop isn't exactly
invading poland but louis philippe the first
clearly didn't agree in 1838 the french king
suddenly demanded mexico pay compensation not only
to the offended baker but to every other frenchman
who'd had property damaged in mexico too still
it was the pastry shop that stuck in everyone's
minds which is why the french mexican conflict
of 1838 has gone down in history as the pastry
war that it helped santorana return to power was
sheer dumb luck when it came time to invade the
french fleet landed at veracruz bamin santarana
was the only guy capable of leading the defense
and lead it he did raising an army he charged
down sent the french into retreat and chased
them all the way to the harbor their grape shot
from a cannon mangled his left leg forcing it to
be amputated although mexico ultimately lost
the war and turned hirana his leg the optics
couldn't have been better suddenly santa anna was
no longer the domas who lost texas but the hero
who'd sacrificed his own leg protecting mexico
it was a complete rehabilitation so popular did
santa ana become following the pastry war that
when the presidency again became vacant in 1841
there was only one clear replacement santarana's
transformation from outcast to hero president
was likely his greatest change so far yet it would
also become his weirdest by now mexico's man of
destiny was firmly buying into his own hype that
inflated ego soon led him to do some crazy ass
stuff the story of santa anna's leg tends to be
the other thing that people know about him because
it's just so bad crazy after the pastry war the
cordillo had buried his leg at his hacienda now
he was president again he had it dug up placed in
a crystal coffin and given a full military burial
in mexico city there was a parade cannons were
fired diplomats read speeches it was in short
vainglorious access like mexico had never seen
before yet it was a mere taster of what was to
come while santorana's earlier presidency had been
marked by increasing centralization his new reign
aside from a brief pause when he stepped down in
1842 was far weirder like augustine santarana had
become fixated on the idea of mexico needing a
monarch him while he didn't quite declare himself
king he did force people to call him his most
serene highness and started signing his letters
santa anna savior of the fatherland general of
division knight of the great cross at the royal
and distinguished spanish order of charles iii
president of the mexican republic grand master of
the national and distinguished order of guadalupe
statues to him sprague up across mexico city
streets were renamed after him leaders forced to
empty their coffers for his most serene highness
but just like augustine santa ana also
underestimated his country's tolerance for
a decadent monarch the last straw came
in 1844. that year sanchez's wife died
but rather than grieve the 50 year old
announced that he would get married again
this time to a 15 year old for mexican society
this was just too much rebellions exploded for
the tenth thousandth time unable to raise an
army sanjarana was forced to flee the capital
he was captured by an indigenous tribe who told
the government they'd be happy to return him as a
tamale in other words cooked and turned into snack
food but the new powers were done worrying about
santorena instead the dictator was sent once again
into exile once again so disgraced that no one
could imagine him ever staging another comeback
once again though everybody would be proved wrong
by now should be clear that the key to santa
ana's hold over mexico wasn't that he was
uniquely charismatic or capable although he
was certainly the former it's that mexico
in this half century was so unstable that there
was simply no way anyone got a cordillo could
hope to hold on to power that went double when
the instability came from outside like from say
a certain northern neighbor the election of james
k polk to the white house in 1844 would turn out
to be the most destabilizing event yet polk was
ruthlessly dedicated to expanding america in 1845
he authorized the annexation of texas which mexico
still laid claim to but it's really what came next
but blew things up in 1846 polk dispatched troops
to the disputed mexican texan border considering
this an invasion a mexican unit shot at them
killing 12. in retaliation congress declared war
the outbreak of the mexican-american war ended
the centralist republic the government collapsed
over in cuba san tyrannosaurus chance opening
a communication channel with polk he offered to
retake mexico's presidency and settle the war on
generous terms all park had to do was let him run
the blockade and get into his country evidently
unaware of santa ana's reputation polk agreed no
sooner had tantarana landed then he switched sides
again rustling up an army to fight the americans
it was a move which saw his street cred shoot up
but it wasn't enough to save mexico santarana's
army was equipped with surplus from the napoleonic
era no match for american weapons while they did
win some battles there was just no way they could
win the war mexico city fell in september of 1847.
although santa ana tried to fight on raising a
guerrilla movement a hairy american supply lines
his latest comeback was over once again he was
stripped of the presidency once again he was sent
into exile once again it would just be temporary
the treaty the americans forced on mexico you
see was nearly as destabilizing as the actual war
mexico lost over half of its territory unable to
cope with such a catastrophic defeat subsequent
government simply collapsed one after the other
by 1853 the nation was an unholy mess so much so
that the conservative faction hatched a plan to
dispense with democracy altogether turning mexico
into a monarchy they just needed someone strong in
charge while the details were ironed out just for
a year say until they could convince some european
royal to come over and be king and can you
guess who they chose on april 20 1853 santorana
returned to power for the final time as usual he
double-crossed everybody once he was secure he
killed the plans to invite some random royal over
and instead made himself emperor in orbit name
he would rule for life choose his successor once
again he would be called his most serene highness
but well mexicans didn't like this any more than
they had the previous two times in the end santa
ana's final undoing was just exiling leading
liberals instead of killing them from abroad one
liberal benito juarez hatched a plan to depose the
undeclared emperor with the help of a general in
mexico he directed an uprising that chased santa
ana from power for the billionth time this time no
one but no one expected it to be the end surely
santa ana would come back again and again like
a slash a movie villain that can't be killed alas
once again though everyone was wrong santorana's
1855 xr marks the last time he ever had any
influence on mexican politics what followed
was an era dominated by benito juarez one only
broken when the conservatives finally got their
wish and managed to install an emperor with french
help but they didn't pick santa anna to lead their
empire for the next few decades santorana bounced
around the caribbean waiting for what he called
his inevitable chance to return he tried to stage
another comeback just after the second mexican
emperor fell only to be tried for treason and sent
back into exile this time the state confiscated
most of his property and his serene highness was
now penniless finally in 1870 president benito
juarez announced a general amnesty for all exiles
still santorana waited until his old rival had
died before slinking back home in 1874. by now
mexico's man of destiny was old partially deaf
nearly blind forgotten by a country that had long
ago moved on unable to make another bid for power
mexico's great survivor died alone in poverty
on june 21 1876. before the year was out another
cordial would have seized power known as porfirio
diaz he became the dictator santa anna had dreamed
of being ruling with an iron fist for 34 years
compared to the other larger than life figures of
mexican history santorana is today semi-obscure a
villain in texas's origin story a funny long dead
tyrant who once gave his own leg a state funeral
certainly his impact has been smaller than that of
pofferio diaz or don miguel hidalgo or benito
juarez or well almost any other big name his
time at the top was a weird interlude when a vain
strong man managed to fool people into thinking
that he was the mexican napoleon yet this view
does send her hana a disservice here was a leader
who is nothing if not a product of his time an
agent of chaos born from one of the most chaotic
periods the nation ever experienced the saying
goes cometh the hour cometh the man in santa rana
for better and for worse mexico found
the perfect man for an imperfect era
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and thank you for watching